tell us about uh when you when you were
acting in a movie with patrick swayze oh
um
christmas in wonderland yeah i had a
christmas movie where i played a
criminal uh with i played chris kittan's
brother
and uh we uh rob uh patrick swayze's
kids from with of their money
in the movie it is a big flop but it was
sure fun to make i remember you just
saying like the greatest things about
patrick swayze
he was i hung out with him every night
spent a lot of time we were sitting
there i was sitting there with patrick
swayze and i said because we started to
be buddies and i said it's a shame we
could never get you on our show to be
work with chris and he goes what are you
talking about he goes i would have loved
to been on that and i said no we went
repeatedly to your agents and he goes
i'm going to call him he goes because
insurance heck never went to me and it
was like man these darn agents just
because it's no money won't do it you
know
and it's just like it would have been
could have brought him back you know
what i mean could have been great for
his career brought him back i don't know
i didn't know that he had he called this
christmas movie that he did his comeback
because he had such a gap in his in his
mind
yeah
and then he ended up doing uh one like
horror series after that
then he did ghosts now this is before
the ghost was a long time ago there's a
big gap there yeah your timeline is all
yeah should be a nice guy too yeah
super nice how did you get along with
chris katan real good real good he was
great and carmen electra too she was a
husband i'm in a lecture yeah she was
like we went and to see uh sting play at
a big football stadium and they said
sting is backstage and he wants to meet
you so i walk up there
us so it's carmen electra chris katan
patrick swayze and me and sting goes i
know you and pointed right at me and
walks up there and says he's a big
jackass fan i couldn't believe it and
chris katana was like i was in a skit
with him on saturday night live he and
he's saying that it comes up to your fat
ass
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you